bonsoir j'ai ri alors on va prendre les
choses par le commencement
on va te faire une interview première
fois est ce que tu es prêt je suis tout
à fait prêt bon alors ton premier non
c'est pas du tout est vrai qu'en matière
dense et gaston ghrenassia à l'agenda
serré ghrenassia exactement parce que ma
première pochette c'était gaston
ghrenassia oui et le directeur de
commercial de mam et une première maison
de disque et il n'arrivait jamais à se
rappeler de mon nom oui et alors il a
demandé à ce que je le change
moi ça me plaisait pas tellement mais
enfin bref j'ai dit bon je vais le coupé
comme j'étais déjà coupé une première
fois j'ai je vais couper mon cousin
grave elle a comparé le prénom c'est
gaston gaston alors où gaston c'est
formidable parce que moi je voulais le
garder
j'ai toujours eu du succès à l'école
avec gaston à chaque fois on me disait
comment comment tu t'appelles gaston
drapeau ça faisait marrer tout le monde
oblige était le copain tout le monde
mais prenez pas mal quoi qui t'appelle
encore gaston personnes à 6-6 mais à gaz
mais ma femme avant mais mes copains
intime ceux qui m'ont connu depuis le
début ils m'appellent pas enrico alors
ton premier souvenir c'était rue
biscarra à constantine non oui c'est de
la glisse carraway y avait des
catholiques y avait des juifs et des
musulmans qui vivaient ensemble sans
beaucoup de problèmes à l'époque là bas
oui surtout que moi je suis né dans un
quartier
il faut dire que à constantine avait
trois quartiers bien distincts le
quartier juif le quartier chrétien
quartier musulman mais moi je suis né
dans un quartier où toutes les
communautés étaient réunis alors il n'y
avait pas du tout de problème
ton premier chèque dans la vie c'était
quoi la guerre d'algérie c'est sûr mais
les premiers attentats
les bombes
du sas sas homme tué ça c'est un truc
qui marque qui m'a profondément choqué
parce que j'ai pas eu une jeunesse de
l'enfance on est passé directement aux
épreuves aux responsabilités ta première
guitare
je me rappelle quand j'étais tout petit
j'ai j'allais chez le menuisier je
prenais une planche et puis avec une
boîte d'allumettes
et puis des élastiques que j'arrive à
faire un petit instrument mais mon
premier instrument m'a été offert pour
moi ma grand-mère et ça je n'oublierai
jamais et c'est fou de toi tes grands
parents
ah oui mais moi j'étais fou mais mon
pardon j'avais 12 ans étant premier
amour c'est suzy ma femme mais ouais
elle t'a abordés par les caves et des
nattes avec des petits noirs au bout des
nattes lt abordé dans la ville tout
avait honte d'être en culottes courtes
c'est vrai ça c'est à dire que comme
j'étais un peu trapu
non non mais moi je me rappelle de suzy
quand on était petits c'était citepa et
le crime aborder ces thèmes qui ramait
pour le prologue pour l'om et parce que
pour qu'elle ait dit oui j'ai mis du
temps
alors ton premier voyage en france et
s'est passé comment c'est ton père
voulait mettre dans une école juive
traditionnelle en france
oui elle était restée dix minutes
comment ça s'est passé tu crois que tu
es au courant de vos boutures et ce
n'est pas non c'est vrai pied une
aubaine extraordinaire un jour je dis à
mon père papa il ya plus professeur
c'est la guerre et où il n'y a pas un
moyen de partir j'ai une bourse je peux
avoir une bourse devrait continuer mes
études en france là au moins je pourrai
avoir des diplômes et tout et puis
j'arrive à le convaincre c'était la
maman ma première
la première fois que j'arrivais à
convaincre mon père et ma mère surtout
mon père qui était un peu dur avec moi
mais enfin je regrette pas
papa c'est que dieu nous les gardes et
voilà que j'arrive donc il m'a inscrit
dans une école juive puis j'arrive je
suis reçue par la directrice de l'école
puis elle me dit comment vous appelez
jeudi ghrenassia gaston tu saint julien
de constantine est dit il n'avait pas la
kippa visible pourquoi il faut un petit
pas pour venir à la sec mène synagogue
civile et qu elle me dit il faut une
kippa voilà je suis plus retourné et là
tu es allé au lycée carnot à
fontainebleau oui j'avais un cousin qui
était
étudiant à l'époque et j'ai c'était un
de mes seuls parents avec ma tante la
soeur de mon père et je lui ai dit il
faut que tu me trouves une école parce
que je vais être obligé de retourner à
constantine et je ne veux pas enfin
d'autres à découvert le racine
c'est-à-dire s'éveille à un jour un type
qui est à 10 mois les juifs un premier
jour je suis arrivée je vais pris en
plein dans la gueule c'était un élève
com - pensionnaires il s'appelait de la
masse vous rappellerai tout tout le
temps
il m'a pris pour un musulman pour
l'algérien de là bas et comme je suis
bronzé j'ai le type j'ai pas le type
suédois pendant leur garde comme ça qui
me dit attention moi j'ai rien contre
les arabes mais par contre une race que
je ne supporte pas c'est les juifs
bon je lui donnais un coup de poing mais
voilà au conseil de discipline
je voulais voir le dans le club du vice
et de fontainebleau il faisait un peu la
gueule il voulait pas trop et puis un
jour il ya un décor s'effondrer et toi
tu as commencé à jouer comme ça c'est
vrai ça oui c'est vrai c'est une pièce
de de prévert puis moi jouer leur le
rôle d'un capitaine et j'avais une
phrase un mot à dire en avant on a dit
virer sortait j'ai pas réussi à se dit
quand même il faut que je fasse quelque
chose
j'ai dit je savais je chante et je joue
de la guitare l'angelus et chantre et
même sur son mon pays je me dis mais
qu'est ce que c'est ça allait non non ça
n'a pas marché
il a fallu que à la fête du lycée de
fontainebleau j'ai une chance inouïe
le décor de la pièce qui s'effondre et
pour meubler il m'appelle d'urgence je
vais chercher ma guitare au lycée et
j'ai meublé j'ai chanté des chansons je
veux dire que j'ai pas eu tellement de
succès mais ça m'a donné le goût des
planches et c'est comme ça que je suis
devenu chanteur mais c'est vrai qu'il
faisait le mur à fontainebleau pour
aller jouer dans des cabarets venais de
voir qu'ils s'en rendent pas reconnaître
non non c'est pas ça c'est que j'avais
trouvé une astuce je chantais masqué sur
une gondole la scène c'était une gondole
et je disais que j'étais un chanteur de
venise aymeric au jeu anglais
et sa guitare un jour j'ai été belle oui
c'est bel et bien mais personne ne me
reconnaissez les premières fleurs c'est
avec suzy ah bon avec fusil puis par la
suite on a eu d'autres expériences quand
même oui j'espère justement la première
fois que la fed annonce et avec suzy nom
avait quitté en souvient oui c'était une
je me rappelle ses perf en plein boom
c'était vraiment la madone du tout le
lycée je crois que tous les lycées y est
passé c'est la vérité et en plus c'était
facile elle était nettement plus vieille
que nous c'était notre madone la
première cuite c'est en souviens c'était
aussi aux 17 travailleurs n'étaient pas
venus pour rien à manger ton premier
jour j'ai fumé un joint une fois dans ma
vie c'est au canada j'étais avec avec
plein de copains et puis un jour je me
suis trouvé seul dans la chambre et le
mon copain m'avait donné un joint mais
pour fumer avec 30 personnes moi j'ai pu
mais pour moi bus
on raconte même étage et et ça m'a
dégoûté pour que les clarines porte que
la vie est le premier disque était
acheté le premier disque que j'ai acheté
c'est celui de mon beau père parce qu'il
faut que je vous dise que mon père et
mon beau père avait un magasin de
disques où il pouvait être très très
très riche en vendant les disques de
tout le monde mais il vend dès que les
disques de leur orchestre et donc les
premiers disent que j'ai eu c'est
excellent de mon beau père